what do these words have in common
there's a door in my house I never open
even in October when I hear that strange
knock knock
you're probably suspicious that things
like these are lurking on the other side
of that door words that hide the unknown
but you're not scared by plain lexical
items I mean you need context a
narrative a scary story the kind that
has an unknown Menace that
psychologically intimidates your
characters add +1 points if the Menace
is linked to wider social ills a sense
of despair or hopelessness that comes
over your audience as they fear that the
Menace is too powerful to handle a
MacGuffin a person or object that drags
us into the depths of fear without
distracting us from the main story a
plot twist for added suspense and if
yours is a psychological thriller add
another plus one if by the end we find
out that the narrator telling us this
true tale is also unreliable true
so there's your scary story checklist
good night happy Halloween
what where did it come from
okay sure that story tellers of old knew
how to spin tales with monsters and
ghosts like in Homer's Odyssey spirit
possession and Lady Murasaki's tale of
genji or even spooky settings as the dog
tease in
Ferno ancient Sanskrit drama theorists
even shrewdly separated that personal
feeling of anticipation you have sitting
there alone with your heart beating
faster and faster and faster from the
shared sentiment of terror that descends
over the entire audience and the
reaction of or follows but these hi
artists were focused on telling a
perfectly balanced tale not indulging
our fears for hours on end and then
there's folklore hmm local lowly tales
of the shape-shifting Aswang
haunting the forests of the Philippines
or of spirits exiting the Otherworld to
walk the earth during the Celtic sowon
sowon the very same harvest holiday
behind our Halloween aha folklore and
horrible full of strange mysterious
supernatural tales but the path from one
to the other isn't really direct it took
a reaction the kind that happened in the
Enlightenment as Europe grew more and
more rationally sophisticated and then
Romanticism reacted with pure raw
emotion usually those emotions were nice
emotions but of course not all emotions
are nice one of these emotions was the
sublime the immense shock and all you
feel when looking at mountains or huge
gothic buildings philosopher Edmund
Burke talked about this the idea of
horror and terror being feelings of the
sublime plain and terror are capable of
producing delight a sort of delightful
horror a sort of tranquility tinged with
terror we want to be scared we enjoy it
how
novelist took this dark emotional
journey and created the Gothic trend
around that time turning medieval
castles towns priests and monsters into
objects of fear over time novels movies
and games capitalized on these dark
emotions to engineer our scary story
checklist take that funny word MacGuffin
sure our story needs a menace fear
uncertainty and surprise but Alfred
Hitchcock thought what if we had an
extra item that grabs our interests and
pulls us along here's a recent example
sort of raising a little old skeleton
key may not ultimately determine whether
or not the spirits in the Attic will
snatch our bodies tonight but it
certainly keeps us curious long enough
to stick around and find out what
happens next modern horror uses elements
like these to tighten our experience of
fear from start to finish so from
folklore to rationalism to Romanticism
to gothic to modern horror we have a
whole history of scary prose to thank
for this basic checklist we come to love
or fear love to fear
so if pong scares poetry must hold head
over to my channel critical it to find
out more